[Music]
today was pope benedict's last day at
work can you believe that don't be sad
yeah right now all the other Cardinals
are buying him shots at the Vatican
Applebee's I'm gonna miss you I'm gonna
miss you
we'll stay in touch one thing I won't
miss it's the food in the commissary
your pope sounds like Dracula today the
Pope spoke to over 100 cardinals and
said among you is the future Pope yeah
then the Pope said now enter the Octagon
they're gonna fight it out apparently it
was amazing with holy relics chalices
and st. bones Saints bones if you're
gonna fight with Saints bow you said
relics I didn't get too specific this is
a little ominous we are now I think 24
hours away from going into massive
across-the-board budget cuts yeah if the
budget cuts go into effect this is true
major airports could face delays of up
to 90 minutes
or as JetBlue calls it an on-time
departure this is serious though
automatic budget cuts could negatively
affect water and sewage services yeah
you know the words all of America is
about to embark on a Carnival Cruise
[Applause]
for a really good one I get the hat yeah
in Ohio a 106 year old woman a hundred
and six year old woman is finally about
to get her high school diploma which
means next month she'll start visiting
colleges with her parents
[Applause]
yahoo has redesigned its home page in an
effort to get people to visit more
frequently yeah they've also changed
their url to google.com just gets to it
right away at a anyone Direction fans
here kind of appropriate and then one
older guy at a One Direction concert in
Scotland a fan threw a shoe that hit
Harry Styles in the crotch then for the
rest of the concert he's sang with a
man's voice
[Applause]
I like how you decide now you're like
yeah
the whole show is in your hands
I like it speaking of music
former kiss star Ace Frehley is facing
foreclosure on his New York home yet to
save money the former kiss guitarist
will only rock and roll half the night
and party every other day two Americans
who were reported missing have been
discovered in perfect health
living in the Peruvian jungle yeah
personally I'm just glad that Heidi and
Spencer are okay stay where you are
[Applause]
I got you now big news out of the NFL
shut up my own people are laughing at me
the NFL is warning teams that they are
not allowed to ask the potential draft
pick if he's gay yeah whoever they are
allowed to ask him to go deep and see
what he does
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nicely done thank you